today I'm transforming into one of her
his most famous window singers scene up
out guys one of our Salvador his most
celebrated artists Tonio Salazar I'll be
playing a video for him I think just
growing up he was always like this like
icon that women looked up to she was
fighting for labor rights I'm an ism
before that was really a movement she
had a charity and a foundation he would
make caricatures of people who were just
dicks in history kind of do commentary
through his artwork he was sassy with
his artwork and I'm a little sassy with
my word I grew up listening to Dean
about gar my grandpa would play it all
the time in the car her music has
impacted me so much because it reminds
me so much of my grandpa every time I
listen to it I just get so emotional
she's an icon or you know very powerful
I'm very proud to tell my family that I
got a plague of eat a bit on my hair
such a big part of my identity I felt
like a different person
my grandpa would have loved to see me
transform into Dean I he was kind of
pushing for rights for all people like
I'm doing that in my own way now
I feel the sort of connection to him
[Music]
she wasn't afraid to dream and she let
her music speak for herself her music is
just so soulful and it really just makes
you feel something
[Music]
she sounds like it's like you know it's
like mythological beings but I think she
still has so much impact even years
after her death
[Music]
it was really cool to like channel my
Peruvian route
[Music]
he has a Cinderella story she was
cleaning homes she was selling food on
the streets she always had her dream of
singing and she's so passionate about it
[Music]
being the sad and even seeing the things
like the tool is in the paint I just was
imagining what was life like what was it
like to be this creative person back
then and to be making political
statements through your artwork
[Music]
I think someone like Evita is definitely
someone to always remember by
[Music]
you know we're trying to picture her in
her most passionate time which is when
she was giving speeches to the people
and she was very big with her arms had
very big arm movement a really great
experience kind of you know remembering
what she stood for and learning more
about her I'm definitely proud of II
Argentinian I was just exciting to just
shine a little bit of light on somebody
who represents my country in the best
way she's a very proud Peruvian woman
who's killing it and I'm just so proud
to be able to transform into her today
[Music]